[Musique]
certains des roms expulsés décide de
repartir quelques semaines en roumanie
depuis l'entrée de ce pays dans l'union
européenne les roms ont le droit de
circuler librement dans toute l'europe
et vous allez voir que les
allers-retours sont soigneusement
organisé chauffeur voiture tu arrives
tout est prévu et le système fonctionne
parfaitement bien
nous avons réussi à identifier un de ces
réseaux
nous sommes dans la banlieue parisienne
cet homme a accepté de nous emmener
jusqu'en roumanie
tarzan et chauffeurs il se prépare pour
un long voyage
il possède deux camionnettes une jaune
et une blanche conduite par un employé
tarzan soigne le service il va chercher
ses clients à domicile dans les camps
les passagers en même temps roumanie
tout ce qu'ils ont récupéré en france
pendant des mois voire des années
il est 17 heures
tarzan emmène quatre familles douze
personnes au total pour un périple de
deux mille kilomètres
deux fois par semaine tarzan travers ce
quatre pays france allemagne autriche
hongrie avant d'arriver en roumanie
combien de temps va m on va rouler
pendant 22 heures 22 heures quasiment
sans arrêt dans son minibus damian sa
femme et leurs deux enfants en france
ils vivent de la mendicité
cela fait deux ans qu'ils ne sont pas
rentrés chez eux je dois rentrer
aujourd'hui car ma maison s'est écroulée
il faut que je la répare pour avoir un
endroit où habiter le jour où je
déciderai de rentrée damian va retrouver
là-bas ses quatre autres enfants ils ont
trouvé refuge dans la famille tu es
content de rentrer en roumanie
non je suis obligé de rentrer en
roumanie
je n'ai pas la possibilité de donner à
manger à ma famille je ne peux pas les
aviez je préfère rester en france pour
essayer de m'en sortir pour damian un
voyage comme celui ci représente une
petite fortune 100 euros par adulte 50
euros par enfant 300 euros au total pour
éviter les péages tarzan prend la
nationale et pour passer le temps les
voyageurs regarde des dvd des clips de
musique tzigane
[Musique]
à
peut-être
[Musique]
après une nuit de trajet nous arrivons
en autriche
cela fait 15 heures que nous roulons
c'est la première étape
tout le monde s'arrête là les roumains
et les bulgares tout le monde s'arrête
là cette aire de repos est connue de
toute la communauté pour les passagers
c'est l'occasion de se dégourdir les
jambes et de rencontrer d'autres roms
qui vivent en france
monsieur pour reprendre des forces
les voyageurs font une halte à la
cafétéria des trajets comme celui ci
floriane simone et leur fils en font
deux parents cela fait cinq ans qu'ils
vivent en france
une demi heure plus tard il faut déjà
repartir et mes jetons drôme mais je te
semble audois michto jusqu'à maintenant
ça va c'est bien dormi super mais picot
hélas pas dormi l'avait pas flou rien et
sa famille ont payé 250 euros pour le
voyage
s'ils rentrent en roumanie c'est pour
voir leurs quatre filles et aussi pour
ramener de l'argent au pays
parce que le web la raison tu du ventre
avec tous bien d'argent
marc simon
enfin tu as rêvé
saman
monde y gagne de l'argent en france à ce
qu'annonce aaron travail de voir
gamache
ne pas y est
ça valait le prince
encore quelques kilomètres et le convoi
arrive en hongrie
[Musique]
dans ce pays tardan conduit plus
lentement pour ne pas attirer
l'attention des policiers
même s'il n'y a pas de problème ils
peuvent toujours te trouver un problème
d'argent sait de quoi il parle
lors de son dernier voyage il affirme
qu'il a dû donner 450 euros aux
policiers hongrois le genre d'imprévu
qui réduit considérablement ses
bénéfices
pour le moment ils passent la frontière
sans problème mais une centaine de
kilomètres plus loin une voiture de
police nous arrête
toi qui nous ont pas loupé un il
attendait plus en tarzan décent nous
l'accompagnons mais le policier nous
demandent immédiatement de remonter dans
la camionnette
vous vous restez là bas j'ai pas envie
d'y aller la première parce que manger
tu as entendu ces paroles perdues mais
ça se comprend tu peux pas y aller tôt
non non tu as bien lu il manquerait pas
de témoins tarzan se retrouve seul avec
les policiers nous filmons de loin avec
une caméra cachée
quelques minutes plus tard tard on
reprend le volant que s'est il passé
il voulait que je paye 100 euros pour
défaut de siège enfant
[Musique]
tu as pays a payé
je lui ai donné 40 euros dans l'âme 1,40
euro bah oui je préfère donner 40 euros
un policier plutôt que de payer une
amende à 100 euros
tu vois finalement la corruption ça
arrange tout le monde
après trente heures de voyage soit 8 de
plus que prévu nous passons enfin la
frontière roumaine
c'est à tim k à l'ouest du pays que
tarzan dépose sa première passagère
il s'arrête juste devant chez elle pour
le chauffeur c'est maintenant l'heure de
se faire payer ses 100 euros pour la
dame
il est minuit parents repart pour
déposer les autres passagers combien tu
gagnes pour une personne et je me fais
entre 400 et 500 euros à raison de deux
voyages par semaine
tarzan gagneraient donc plus de 3000
euros par mois net d'impôt c'est
maintenant au tour de florian et simone
d'arriver à la maison
à notre grande surprise ici ils ne
vivent pas dans une baraque en planche
mais dans une vraie maison en briques
avec l'électricité et tout le confort
après quatre mois d'absence ils
retrouvent leurs quatre filles laissées
sur place
je suis contente ah oui oui c'est
marrant basket moi moi paul pour une
mise à faire porter les fonds sous
l'effet de la louge pourrait arriver si
coléreux les données manger les données
huit mois et les données mais pour le
moment simone a du travail
elle doit ranger tout ce qu'ils ont
ramené de france ici à grand pas vers
est ici c'est comme ça que de la
vaisselle ou la vie mais c'est ici c'est
comme ça pour lever pour moi des choses
il aurait dit un jour et si c'est moche
aussi causé c'est comme ça pour les
manger l'épaule et des couvertures et du
mois s'attend trouvé sarah les poubelles
dans la rue encore si c'est ça oui tu
veux pas acheter trop cher récupérer
tron et les poubelles peut l'ouvrir
rapidement comme ça le 2 le dessus pour
moi
déjà compliqué demain marocaine humains
d'accord n'a pas la cote du marché du
film et chante usa match alors on
viendra demain
le lendemain nous retournons voir simone
et florian ils vivent à l'entrée du
quartier rom nous remarquons de belles
villas et aussi plusieurs maisons en
construction dont celle de simone et
florian c'est grâce à l'argent gagné en
france que les roms financent leurs
travaux mais nous allons découvrir
qu'ils n'ont pas très envie d'en parler
t'es sûr qu'ils n'ont pas la florange
pas les dire un mot on aux pattes je
voudrais parler il veut pas me parler
mais tu peux pas me donner juste une
raison on me dira juste pourquoi
non tu veux pas me dire au moins que je
comprenne bon merci au revoir
sipa film et moi j'ai compris ce que
simone ne veut pas nous montrer c'est sa
grande maison en construction une villa
qui n'a rien à voir avec la vie de
mendiantes qu'elle mène en france
[Musique]